[Music]
dan is in
iowa city iowa hi dan how are you
veteran i deserve dave how are you just
the same sir what's up
awesome first i just wanted to say thank
you to you and christy for everything
you guys do you guys are so awesome and
such an inspiration so i really
appreciate you guys thank you for saying
that
um my question today dave is about early
retirement so
for background context i'm 24. my annual
income is about 37
000 a year i have no debt my car's paid
for
and i heard you say you know a couple
times that
when you before you get married when you
buy a house and then you get married you
realize you bought their own house
yeah so i don't know when i'm getting
married but i
wanted to call in and see like what what
would you prioritize in my
situation would you prioritize early
retirement if
if the goal was reachable and say five
years or would you put the money in a
mutual fund towards
a sizable down payment or preferably a
cash purchase on a home
a small home
[Music]
okay let's go back a second because
you're 24
and early retirement is in five years so
you're from 29 years old
on for the rest of your life what are
you going to do
i would like to start my own company um
i want to do something in e-commerce
that um sort of like is my ministry tool
i'm a part-time photographer outdoor
photographer
and i you know a lot of my friends like
98
of my friends okay so by retirement you
don't mean go fishing
by retirement you mean and you don't
have to work a regular job and you can
go live your dream of owning your own
business
yeah exactly just financial freedom and
just supplemental income from
investments
gotcha okay all right good um
well i think you can start making moves
towards that
now i don't think that requires that you
be financially independent
a lot of people don't right as a matter
of fact it might be your shortest path
to financial independence because if you
got your business up and running you
might make more than thirty seven
thousand dollars
that's true yeah
yeah what made me ask the question dave
is because um i i listen every day and
have for about a year now
and i'm on i'm on baby step i guess
you'd say i guess you'd say four
um so i've been investing 15 percent
um but wanted to know like okay what do
i prioritize because my expenses are so
low
so like rent aside um my my yearly
expenses dave are only two thousand
dollars a year
that's right um just with my my only
bills are car insurance
phone um so you're living at home that's
really
it um no so i just
i usually i move around a lot so my rent
is kind of
hard to say like what it is for a full
year but it's usually between
350 and 450 and so i'm that's more than
2 000
a year
yeah i i just wanted to do retirement
just so i could like
um basically set up early retirement so
that when i'm in the place where i don't
have a rent or mortgage payment
um i uh i would be able to focus on that
okay let's let's change the word from
retirement to you just want to build
some wealth
okay sure and um so i think you can
uh begin to work on your
new idea for your business as a side
hustle
don't you christy yeah sure start that
now you're going to learn a lot in the
process you don't have to wait till some
magic five years from now or certain
income to be able to do it start now and
learn about what you want to do and what
the market needs
yeah let's get that going and let's um
uh you know start that and and get your
income up and when the income gets close
to what you make now go ahead and start
working
and living your dream don't wait until
you have a pile of money to go live your
dream
it's not necessary um sure i i haven't i
started
two businesses both of which were very
successful one of which failed later my
real estate business
but i started both of them with
literally nothing um
and got started so you can do that now
and ease into this
and organically let you could take all
the money you make in the business port
back into the business
and just live off of your day job and
that's fine until you get the thing up
and running
and so if that's working then that
doesn't require
any investing then we can say oh let's
redirect all your cash towards paying
cash for your first house
and that's probably what i would do at
that point i would just go that
direction
so uh because you know and then if you
do buy a house and it's the wrong one
you can sell it
another one if you get married all that
kind of that joke and all that stuff
that we talk about but
it's joke based in fact but um but the
uh uh but yeah that's that's you know i
i don't think that you need a half a
million dollars in a paid for
house in order to start your business
you know what's interesting is you know
he's young asking this question it's
actually similar to what we were just
talking about before the break where
your priorities change and when you're
young and and you
you have a small sense of what you want
to do but you can't predict the future
none of us can you can say okay what do
i want to do based on what i know today
based on what i know today is i want to
build wealth i want to start a business
let's start on the side
i'd like to get married but i'm not
dating anybody i'd like to buy a house
but i don't have the money yet
so let's just do what we can do today
with what we know today what we have
today
that's what's in your phrase you said
earlier what's right right now right and
then in three years five years get
married by house what's right then
good